what's something about storytelling you
wish that you had learned earlier
in your career or you wish you'd stuck
your guns on
maybe people tried to talk you out of it
i guess i
wish i knew how much
how much more important character
development was to writing
i think that was i don't think i
developed the characters enough
when i started writing and i think
that's where
i if i had if i had known to take more
time to develop the characters i think i
would have
less or would have had less of a
challenge
in either the writing or the rewriting
especially the rewriting
because i think when you you've got a
draft you're going through it you're
looking for the problems
you see the problems and
[Music]
sometimes the solution is
in the bio of the character it's
something that you
you haven't put on the page but it's
something about them
and and and so the answer's already
there because you did your homework
before you started writing the script um
so that's
one thing i wish i knew and in terms of
sticking to my
guns i
when i i have i probably have stuck to
my guns
to a fault um
i i'm one thing i'm really bad at is
tolerating fools
and there are a lot of fools in the
entertainment industry
in every industry but i think more in
the entertainment industry
special breed of fool um in what way
um i guess because
they're there's very little
much like people call themselves experts
and
the only thing that makes them an expert
is that they put the word expert in
their bio
and there's no you know it's not like
you
get a doctorate or something you know
you say like i'm a social media expert
really that so you must spend all of
your time learning about the new social
media thing to do
and that's all you're doing um
i'm going off on a tangent i
it's a good tangent yeah um
well you said sticking to your guns to
your detriment you don't think that
that's a good thing
sometimes when you're the writer you're
the employee
and sometimes uh i
have not often
not that many gigs to begin with but a
couple of times i was writing something
that
was stupid and i knew it was stupid
and but the people
who were
[Music]
producing the project who brought me on
had success previously
and and they were convinced this was
going to be their next one
and and i was the guy to do it and
it was a horrible idea that i explained
to them what the
why it was a problem and the chara
the main character wasn't likable in a
way that
would make the audience would never make
the audience care
about the character and so i had to cook
up like this whole other thing and then
explain to them like
we this we need to root for the
character and if the character
is um i remember
uh whoopi goldberg told the story of
writing a screenplay
about a a
hardcore right-wing republican senator
who finds out that he has black blood in
his uh lineage and all of his politics
would make that bad and
uh i can't remember who she went to for
advice
and the person gave them the advice
yeah just throw it out uh and they were
like this is a great idea we have a lot
of interest and people are
yeah who cares who cares what happens
to this republican guy he's a bad person
who discovers
that he's an even worse person like why
are we going
and and the these two producers their
argument was
well you know bill murray in groundhog
day he's very unlikable i'm like yeah
yeah your main character is female so
name me
one mainstream comedy that has an
unlikable female lead
in the history of film
and nobody could come up with one
because it doesn't
work you have to have there has to be a
reason
and and bill murray is bill murray
so you already have you know that
character if that was an
unknown and being unknown with all
unknown cast
that movie would be a harder read
because
he makes that character fun and likeable
and another actor might not be able to
do that as well
um yeah and the thing is it was it was a
horrible idea
and to the best of my knowledge it's
never been made
not surprising so you're saying that
working on characters
flushing them out backstory was
something you wish you had learned
earlier because you said before that you
would go on this legal pad
so that mount that must have been well
that was something i learned yeah when i
first the first screenplay i wrote
was based on a real life situation that
i
cooked the story around it wasn't comedy
and it wasn't
i was based on a hit and run that i was
stopped from photographing by the police
and it was a cover-up and uh
so that the character
it was all plot there was no it was very
little character
and and it was a just a house of cards
plot
too because that's what you know
when you build up this sort of mystery
and and you have this
house of cards and you like oh i need
i need to change that one thing because
that's not going to work and then you
realize that that is connected to all
these other things
and i'm like oh if i change this and i
have to rewrite everything
that is a nightmare if i had the
characters already cooked more
then it would be i think easier to go
into the character bio and the character
mind and look at the plot from that
point of view rather than being sort of
like god here's the plot here
do something come on character do
something
it doesn't work so it was something i
learned and that's where the legal pad
came from because then it was like i can
scribble i can write whatever i want now
this matters no one's ever going to see
this
and that's the other thing to keep in
mind is when you're writing no one's
going to see until you show it to them
enjoy that but we want to show it to
them oh you want to show it to them but
enjoy it when you have it
because when it goes out for notes it's
something else and then it goes out for
more notes and and it gets torn apart
and it's only yours when you're writing
it
and then you give it and then it gets
and it comes back and you
write it and glue it back together and
how's this
do it again until everyone's happy most
likely except you
at least that's been my experience
you